مراسل الجزيره محمد المدهون ومن البنتاجون
مراسل الجزيره فادي منصور ومن طهران براسل
الجزيره نور الدين الدغير نبدا اولا مع
مراسلنا في لندن
قال لك ان تشرح لنا
باختصار الروايه البريطانيه حول عمليه
المصادره هذه لهذا القارب الايراني
نعم جمال الاعلان الصدر عن وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه متعلق بحادثه وقعت الاسبوع
الماضي في الثالث والعشرين شباط فبراير
المنصرم تلقت
الفرقاتر الفرقاتا البريطانيه الموجوده في
مياه الخليج معلومات استخباراتيه من
الشركاء الامريكيين بحسب ما جاء في بيان
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بتحرك زورق سريع
من ايران باتجاه الجنوب يشتبه بحمله شحنات
من الاسلحه تحركت هذه الفرقه لانكاستر
وتحركت ايضا طائره مروحيه من نوع وائل كات
غادرت متنه هذه الفرقاته وتتبعت هذا
الزورق ووجهت له نداءات طلبت من علمتنه
بالتوقف لكنهم تجاهلوا هذه النداءات
وتوجهوا نحو المياه الاقليميه الايرانيه
وعندها قرر الفريق من مشاه البحريه
الملكيه البريطانيه ان يستولوا على هذا
القارب وان يصادروا ما فيه وقد تم ذلك
بالفعل هناك قروض من الاسلحه كما جاء في
بيان وزاره الدفاع صواريخ موجهه مضاده
للدبابات على غرار صواريخ كورنيت الروسيه
ومكونات صواريخ باليستيه متوسطه المدى
وزيره الدفاع البريطانيه بين ولا قال ان
الوجود الدائم لقوات البحريه الملكيه
البريطانيه في مياه الخليج وهذه العمليه
تؤكد التزام المملكه المتحده الراسخ
بالقانون الدولي بالتصدي للانشطه التي
تهدد الامن والسلام في جميع انحاء العالم
وهذه العمليه من قبل الفرقاطه البريطانيه
تشبه عمليتين السابقتين جرتا العام الماضي
في يناير وفبراير من قبل الفرقاطه مونتروس
التي عملت في تلك المنطقه لاربع سنوات
عندما صدرت شحنات اسلحه ايرانيه كما تقول
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وقد جاء ايضا في
البيان الصادر اليوم بان هذه الاسلحه تمثل
انت
لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي المتعلقه بنقل
الاسلحه للحكم محمد والمتعلقه ايضا
بالضوابط على تكنولوجيا الاسلحه الايرانيه
وقد ابلغت بريطانيا الامم المتحده بما جرى
ودعت مفتشيها الى التحقيق والاطلاء
تحول الان الى
البنتا فادي منصور فادي يعني ما اشرت اليه
البحريه البريطانيه
هو التالي بانها تلقت اشاره من مسيره
امريكيه رصدت القارب الايراني وهو يبحر
بسرعه بعد ذلك ان هذا العمليه كانت
بالتعاون مع الامريكيين
نعم يا جمال كما تعلم الولايات المتحده من
خلال حضورها البحري في المنطقه خصوصا
الاسطول الخامس في البحرين لديها مجموعه
من الاطر للتعاون هناك اطار دولي وهناك
اطار اقليمي من اجل ارساء الامن
والاستقرار في المجال البحري في المنطقه
وهي قامت بعدد من العمليات وساعدت الشركاء
خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه مما ادى الى
سبع عمليات اعتراض تقول الولايات المتحده
انها لشحنات اسلحه ومخدرات كانت تذهب من
ايران ويبدو انها تتوجه الى اليمن بما
انها كانت تتبع مسارات في البحر تستخدم
تاريخيا من اجل التهريب الى اليمن في هذا
الاطار في هذه العمليه قالت قياده البحريه
الامريكيه في القياده تابعه للقياده
الوسطى والاسطول الخامس بانها وفرت الدعم
من خلال عمليات الاستطل الجوي للبحريه
البريطانيه مما ادى الى رصد هذا المركب
ومن ثم مصادره الشحنه الموجوده عليه حتى
هذه اللحظه جمال تقول الولايات المتحده
انه خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه ادت هذه
العمليات الى مصادره اكثر من 5000 قطعه
سلاح بالاضافه الى اكثر من مليون و600 الف
طلقه من الذخيره فضلا عن الصواريخ الموجهه
المضاده للدبابات ومكونات
الصواريخ الباليستيه بالاضافه ايضا الى
حشوات الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات وما
قيمته بنحو 80 مليون دولار من المخدرات
المهربه من ايران قائد الاسطول الخامس في
المنطقه الادمنه البرادي اشار الى ان هذا
العمل عملا يشير الى
نيه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ارساء
الاستقرار ومواصله هذا العمل ورغم كل
عمليات الاعتراض ومصادره هذه الشحنات هذا
مثال اخر على الدور الذي تلعبه ايران دور
الخبيث والمزعزع للاستقرار بحسب بيان صدر
عن الاسطول الخامس وفق الادميرال كوبر
وبالتالي هناك عمليات اعتراض متزايده
مسؤوله في البانتاجون رفيعه كانت اشارت
لنا ان هذه الجهود التي تقوم بها الولايات
المتحده وتكثيف هذه العمليات هو ما يؤدي
الى عمليات الاعتراض وهي اشارت في المقابل
بان مد الولايات المتحده طار الى ان تكثيف
ايران محاولاتها ايصال السلاح الى اليمن
يتعلق بالهدنه القائمه حاليا التي انتهت
لكنها مفاعيلها مستمره الولايات المتحده
تحاول الاستفاده من وقت لاعاده تزويد
الحوثيين بالسلاح جمالنا طيب فادي ارجو ان
تبقى معنا نور الدين مراسل جزيره في طهران
ماذا تقول طهران
جمال لحد الساعه ليس هناك اي موقف صادر
سواء على الجهات العسكريه المتهمه عمليا
بانها هي منتقم وراء هذه العمليه او من
الجهاز الدبلوماسي وخاصه الخارجي وهي
المعتاده على الرد على مثل هذه الاتهامات
بكل تاكيد ما حدثه ما تم الاعلان عنه
اليوم من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومن بريطانيا ليس بالجديد هذه العمليه هي
عمليه دوريه
ببحر العرب باتجاه اليمن ودائما عند القاء
القبض على اي سفينه المتهم الاول الذي
توجه اليه الاتهامات هي ايران لكن بكل
تاكيد في كل مرحله من مراحل الاتهام التي
تتلقى ايران تتحدث الخارجيه هنا بالحديث
على كنا ان كل ما يتم الحديث عنه سواء
امريكيا او سواء بريطانيا يدخل ضمن عما
يسمى تسميه طهران بالاخبار الكاذبه
والاخبار الزائفه التي تريد بشكل او باخر
كما تتحدث دائما الخارجه التاثير على
طبيعه العلاقه ما بين ايران وبين دول
الجوار بل تذهب طهران ابعد من ذلك
[موسيقى]
وبالتالي الحديث عن الصواريخ بمعنى اخر ان
ايران بهذا المنطلق هي تخالف القرار
الدولي 22 واحد وثلاثون نعلم وثلاثون نعلم
على ان رفع العقوبات عن التسلح التقليدي
الايراني كان عام 2000 شكرا 20 لكن رفع
التسلح عن الاسلحه التقنيه
نوعيه مثل الصواريخ سيظل قائما الى سبتمبر
2023 وبالتالي حاله هذا هذه المساله
باتجاه ايران بمعنى اخر لحالتها الى
مخالفتها للقانون الدولي والقارات الدوليه
وبالتالي ربما قد تكون له تداعيات وهذا
وتسميه بمحاوله التلاعب بالقانون الدولي
لاستهداف طهران
شكرا لك شكرا كذلك يا محمد المدهون مراسل
الجزيره في لندن والشكر كذلك فهذه منصور
الجزيره متحدثه من البنتا